the variational free energy and it
allows a decomposition in what's called
a complexity term minus accuracy term
the complexity
term uh measures how much the your
beliefs are moving so you can interpret
this as a as a kinetic energy of
information processing the accuracy term
tells you something about how much do I
know about something else this is what
this is the potential energy so there
even also for the so for the free energy
principle you can you can kind of see
this U that it's trying to minimize the
difference between energies if you if
you will yes yes but maybe just to
linger on this a tiny bit what do you
think is the relationship between
entropy and
information um entropy is in information
Theory it's it's it's you you you can
interpret it as a generalization of the
VAR